all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and word has reached my ears that
Stephen Yoon is supposed to be playing
the century in the Thunderbolts film
next year don't know if that's the case
speculation at this point but we're
gonna remaster the old Century story
that we did back in 2016. now for those
of you guys who don't know the Century's
origin is one of the coolest origins in
Marvel Comics he's a really really cool
character when he was introduced he
hasn't really been cool since but the
thing about this is that the century a
little bit of History here I don't know
if you guys care about this but when the
century was introduced he was kind of
the the Paul Jenkins J Lee experiment
and the idea behind this is that what
his story was told Marvel told it from
the perspective that it was like this
old Stan Lee Jack Kirby story that
nobody knew about right that nobody was
aware it was like discarded so at the
time when it was done there was this
great big huge marketing Ploy and
everything and it kind of worked people
basically thought it was a reworked old
Stan Lee story so that's why the the
origin was so popular when it first
happened but the idea behind this and
you guys will see like the Stanley Jack
Kirby influence as we go through this
video but the way this this opens up is
it's literally just Robert Reynolds
opened it like just waking up out of
nowhere right and just shouting that
like quote unquote he's back now one of
the things to know and we'll talk about
who he's talking about here in a second
this century is one of the most powerful
characters to ever exist in the history
of Marvel Comics he's ridiculously op
and so as Robert Reynolds wakes up with
this story it's literally like his wife
like he woke his wife up in the process
and Lindy's kind of like what's going on
and that kind of thing and he kind of
mutters to himself and says nothing you
know just go back to sleep I need to let
the dog out that kind of thing and he
just sort of chalks it up to the idea of
the storm but this is when stuff gets
cool right because he says it wasn't
just your imagination it was real you
know it how long has it been months
years maybe could it have been that long
everything seems so distant as if you're
coming awake from a Perpetual dream
what's happened to you Bob where have
you been and so what he does is he
literally grabs this book and then just
kind of holds his book up to himself now
one of the reasons why this origin is so
cool is because it sort of Teeters on
this idea that that Robert Reynolds is
actually hallucinating everything so he
basically says like you try to remember
how you got here into this house even
but it's as though you're looking at
your memories through someone else's
Eyes Only You know you heard the
laughter it's a sound you promise
yourself you'd never forget no doubt
about it the void has returned after all
this time somehow he's found a way back
to Earth you imagine you can see him
hiding in the storm that'd be just how
he'd make his play if it is the void
he'll be stronger than ever before the
danger will be beyond measure and there
will be only one hope for Humanity you
and so what's so crazy about this is
that this bottle that he holds over the
course of this is gonna kind of tease us
with this idea that he's actually an
alcoholic that he's a schizophrenic that
uses alcohol to cope and so that's where
it's kind of murky because it really
kind of begs you to ask the question is
he actually a superhero or is he just a
guy who's struggling with mental illness
and uses alcohol to get through it and
so what it does is it kind of jumps back
to his origin for a second we'll talk
about the void here in a minute because
it gets nuts but we jump back to his
origin here for a second and this is
where you get the kind of Stan Lee Jack
Kirby feel to it because this is what
their Comics looks like back then right
the old Stanley Jack Kirby stories this
is what they look like right Robbie
discovers the professor's secret formula
gosh this must be the professor's secret
formula gosh you think this must be the
professor's secret formula
that's how those kinds of things were
done right the cover are you ready for
the secret of the century that kind of
thing but it kind of it sort of jumps
back and forth because this old 1960s
art depiction of the century is kind of
him recollecting on his own origin right
his own history that kind of thing so he
genuinely believes that all of this
happened right he says we must be
vigilant Watchdog we're Humanities only
hope his pet dog is called Watchdog and
so it's one of these things where it's
like suddenly a miraculous
transformation takes place the boy glows
with an unknown energy right and it's
one of those things where like as he's
holding this bottle in his hand it says
like using his Newfound Powers Meek
young freshman Robbie Reynolds the
century counters the blows swiftly
that'll put an end to your bullying Buzz
it's that kind of thing right it's it's
just the old school method of
Storytelling because that's how Stanley
and Jack Kirby told stories back then
they were a lot simpler they were to a
degree a lot more light-hearted and
really a lot less serious than the kind
of stories that you see now but through
it all Robert Reynolds is recollecting
on this right he fashioned a suit for
himself right this golden outfit that
matched his name he's the century this
really powerful character that kind of a
thing but the whole time he's just
drinking right and it says like your
golden suit hangs in there untouched
since the day you last wart if the void
truly has returned you'll have no choice
Bob you're going to have to wear it
again you're going to have to become the
century and then he says the super
soldier serum it's been years since you
drank it it's been years and so as he
kind of takes a takes a drink from this
bottle then he starts to smile he almost
kind of begins to liven up and he starts
recollecting over all these old memories
and so if you're familiar with someone
who struggles with alcoholism this is
very familiar to you because for people
who struggle with alcoholism is how they
cope with the various things going on in
their lives not the best way to cope but
it's how they cope drinking alcohol kind
of breathes some life into them to a
degree it lets them sort of get away
from the things that bother them and
falling into that sort of alcoholic
Bliss makes the world more bearable for
them and so that's sort of Grimace and
that frown and that total sense of
unhappiness begins to melt away to begin
to be filled with this kind of warmth
feeling at the end of the day it's all a
lie it's all a ruse being an alcoholic
is not helping you or your life and if
anything it's sitting you down into a
spiral of complete and total
self-destruction but it's one of these
things where he says it comes over you
in a rush warm wonderful and unfluttered
force like a million little exploding
Suns it feels so good and then the
memories flow welcome thoughts of
Glorious past it's as if you just opened
a surprise package you'd sent yourself
in the mail and literally like
recollecting on his own time right
meanwhile the golden guardian of good
leaps to the air impervious to the
effects of the elements around him you
see what's going on here you see that
like as he starts to recollect on these
memories that he has the consumption of
this drink reminds him of a better time
in his life it takes him back to when he
felt like he missed something when his
life had value and his life had meaning
it's beautifully handled the way that
it's done but all the while is
presenting us this idea that it's all
fake and even himself starts to question
this right like that didn't happen did
that happen it was a comic book you read
when you were a kid or on a TV show none
of what you saw was real but the void is
real he has to be real you know him
almost as well as you know yourself
what's wrong with you why is it so hard
to remember and so that brings in the
schizophrenia because schizophrenia by
definition is a person's inability to
distinguish reality from fantasy and so
when you have someone like Robert
Reynolds who's using alcohol to cope and
as he drinks his alcohol these memories
begin to come back to him of when he was
a superhero and the voids coming back
and all that kind of stuff it seems like
he's self-medicating by using alcohol he
even has memories where he teamed up
with the Avengers to fight the void and
the the void defeated all the Avengers
right like Captain America Thor Ant-Man
Iron Man they all fell before the power
of the void and only Robert Reynolds
could defeat him only Robert Reynolds
could save the day and so again kind of
flashing back to the present moment he
says something's happening something
indecipherable you can no more describe
it than swallow your own throat it's
there right in front of you why can't
you see it who who are you and so that's
the thing because it kind of gives us
this darker element to his character and
saying that while the development of his
powers came by way of a modified version
of the super soldier serum which we'll
talk about here in a second the truth
about it is that it basically became a
drug right like he's literally told by
quote unquote the professor the more he
uses the drug the more he's going to
want to use the drug and the more he's
going to have to use the drug the dosage
is always going to have to be upped
every time he uses it to the point that
like he gets violent when there is no
more serum left or when he doesn't have
the ability to use the drug whenever
some kind of barrier gets in his way
that could potentially prevent him from
being the century by consuming the serum
in some capacity he lashes out exactly
the way that you would expect from an
alcoholic or a drug addict or something
like that the fix is the most important
part of their life it's the one thing
they can't live without and the one
thing they have to have talk to any
addiction specialist and they'll tell
you if the addiction is strong enough
they'll do whatever it takes to get it
nothing matters more than getting that
fix and so it's kind of wild here
because he says like when the professor
was talking to him he basically says
like with your powers and with this
serum that you have your powers are
Limitless there's nothing that you
cannot do you've conquered the time
space continuum itself you are
omnipotent you are Immortal You Are by
all standards of measurement a God and
then he even Muses to himself Immortal
it sounds like a dream you once had you
remember it only there was more but
that's where literally the professor
tells him you're gonna have to
eventually bring yourself down off of
this truck you can't stay the century
forever now here's the thing about the
super soldier serum right while it isn't
necessarily explained in this comic it
does hearken back to the Captain America
days so one of the things to know is
that in a lot of ways Captain America
and Marvel Comics everything kind of
rallied around him in some form or
fashion that in the main Marvel Universe
in the Ultimate Universe is a little bit
different and really a little more
grounded and more tangible but whether
you're talking about the Ultimate
Universe and Marvel Comics which is what
the MCU is based off of or you're
talking about the main Marvel Universe
in Marvel Comics which is where the MCU
borrows characters like Kane the
Conqueror and so on and so forth the
long and short of of this is that Steve
Rogers got the super soldier serum Steve
Rogers was frozen in a block of ice but
because he was the most popular test
subject for the super soldier serum
following his disappearance everybody
was trying to derive their own now again
in the Ultimate Universe is more
tangible but the important thing here is
that this serum in particular was an
attempt to duplicate the super soldier
serum of Captain America and then
amplify it and so the serum is
technically a thousand times more
powerful than the serum that Captain
America took and that's what makes the
century so capable that's what allows
them to do things like alter reality and
travel or manipulate time different
things along those lines but again where
he's told by the professor you cannot
use this anymore you have to stand down
his response is no like I'm not worried
about that I've got a Galaxy to save
right like I've got to get out there and
save everything and so what ends up
happening is as he makes his way back
into the house after letting the dog out
he literally says dependent or not you
never really had a choice always the
void and always you as the last line of
defense you'd gain after every turn but
it was a game you really realize you
could not win and now he's coming back
you can feel it it's not just your
imagination is it and that again is
where he starts to question himself is
it really one of these things where he's
imagining it all is it all just kind of
a his schizophrenic episode right some
kind of mental illness and so as he just
kind of keeps going through amusing to
himself he's drinking from the bottle
he's talking about the super soldier
serum how capable it makes him how
powerful he is what he can do all that
kind of stuff you see what's going on
here but you see how we as the reader
are sort of being toyed with by Paul
Jenkins and J Lee he's going insane he's
got schizophrenia he's using alcohol to
cope none of what he's seeing is
actually real none of what's taking
place is an actual thing and so he's
literally like we must be vigilant and
this is where we really get hit with a
sort of schizophrenic episode where
suddenly like the dog manifests in this
almost demonic form and then starts
talking to him right you shouldn't have
opened the door to me Robert I told you
I would return and when Robert Reynolds
kind of lashes out and like you know
fires an energy shot at the dog the
response to the dog which of course is
basically the void manifesting says
pathetic you dirty little junkie did you
really think you could send me away
forever and what then no more Sentry to
soothe Humanity's fervored brow that in
this moment the void presents himself as
what appears to be a physical
manifestation but all the while we're
kind of left to believe is he again just
imagining it is none of what he's seeing
real this is Complicated by the fact
that when Lindy comes in and sees Robert
Reynolds on the ground he had kicked the
dog right so like the dog's not some
demonic being or anything like that it
looks like it's Robert Reynolds just
kind of having this psychotic break and
like attacking his dog in the process
and so Lindy picks up the bottle and
then looks at it and is like you told me
you stopped drinking that you left it
behind all these little Clues begin to
kind of come to Bear the fact that he
had the book in a the bottle in a book
you talk to anybody who is a drug addict
or who has been a drug addict or who has
been an alcoholic and one of the things
I'll tell you is there's always a secret
stash but again it's one of these things
where like Robert riddles here is
showing all the Hallmark signs of a guy
struggling dealing with mental illness
and using alcohol to cope with this
mental illness and Lindy coming in and
saying like I've had enough I can't do
this anymore I can't be a part of you
and your alcoholic issues when she kind
of says well I'm going to go to my
sisters and I'm gonna go spend time
there for a little while the response of
Robert is yeah you should probably go
and that's kind of the breaking point
for her because of course in this kind
of situation she didn't actually want to
leave which really begs the question why
would you say that if you didn't mean it
but she didn't necessarily want to leave
she wanted Robert to tell her to stay no
no you got to stay you got to stay you
got to stay that kind of thing but
ultimately because he genuinely believes
it's best for her to go because the void
is coming back he effectively destroys
his marriage with Lindy right by
literally sending her away so it's kind
of a it's a it's a crazy thing because
following that he begins to Muse to
himself and he says no one remembers
except you you were a hero and your life
was a fabulous roller coaster ride of
Daring and Adventure you and the others
the heroes you were all that stood in
the way of evil and there you remained
until it went away but the end of every
ride is always the beginning of another
you must have suspected it would one day
come to this you'd have to wear this
Century suit again and so when he puts
on the century suit it doesn't look
anything like the one that he used to
wear instead it's basically just a
jacket with a cape that's attached by
clothespins again it looks like he's
crazy it looks like he's struggling with
mental illness
is not because what happens is as he
makes his way out into the yard he
starts to fly starts to levitate in
space and then following this he goes
and seeks out all the superheroes I'm
telling you guys it's one of the best
origin stories in Marvel I mean we're
not done we still have like five other
issues to go right but it's really
really good it's an amazing origin story
and one of the best that was ever
created in the history of Marvel Comics
so with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end next week
we'll be back with issue number two and
I will catch you on later
peace